donc le budget sera voté ce que je leur
dis simplement c'est que cette année il
ya peut-être une différence par rapport
à l'année dernière c'est que nous sommes
aussi en campagne régionale et qu'il y a
une forme d' aberration à être à lhassa
la salle des quatre colonnes de
l'assemblée nationale à aller voir le
figaro alors dire que ils ont raison la
politique que mène le gouvernement n'est
pas une politique de gauche et le soir à
aller distribuer des tracts avec nous
parce qu'on est sur la même liste aux
élections régionales
donc ça c'est là une double faute en
période de campagne d'alain vendu 2 de
melanie brown leur permettra au
gouvernement d'abord ce budget un budget
que j'assume totalement avec fierté
comme l'action que nous avons menée
depuis trois ans mais quand on est sur
les mêmes listes régionales on a plutôt
intérêt à ne pas aller semer le doute
par les déclarations successives au fil
d'une journée dans l'esprit de nos
électeurs vous parler de ce cousin est
ce qu'un jour vous pourriez menacé par
exemple les frondeurs de tout simplement
vous je dis vous l'exécutif de ne pas
leur accorder de circonscription en 2017
si jamais ils continuent à s'opposer à
la politique du mali c'est une question
qui sera réglée par le parti mais c'est
une question qui peut se poser bien
entendu il ya peut-être un certain
nombre d'endroits où elle peut s'opposer
déjà sur le terrain par la réaction des
militants est bien entendu que ces
choses peuvent se poser moi je souhaite
toujours réunir mais à l'évidence si un
certain nombre de députés ne votez pas
le budget à un an et demi les élections
cette question pourrait se poser